MADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
ATKINS WELL FOR JUST BRADFORD
CUT BY IT CHIANG DALLY DODD
ARIZA GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HERTZBERG HILL HUESO-
TATHAM JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MITCHELL
MONNING MORE LOCK MORALE.
NIELSEN HAN PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO SKINNER. TURNED NUMBER Y.
CASKEY WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IT'S PRESIDENT IS
PRESIDENTE TODAY WE HAVE
SENATOR BATES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WE WELCOME SENATOR
BATES- IT CENTER BATES WILL BE
PARTICIPATING IN DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE BUT WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING IN A QUORUM CALL
OR THE VOTE ON MEASURES LAYS
INJURED IN THE SENATE WITH THE
NEIGHBORS IN OUR GET. ON THE
OTHER A- IS WE'RE GONNA. THIS
HAVE TO SENATOR PORTANTINO.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE RE STANDING
WE'RE GONNA BE LED IN THE
NATION'S PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. BY
SENATOR MONEY CENTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS- AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE PLAY A RAISIN IN THE SUN.
LORRAINE HANSBERRY USES
LANGSTON USES PROBLEM HARLEM.
AS INSPIRATION USE WROTE WHAT
HAPPENS TO A DREAM DEFERRED. AS
A DRY UP LIKE A RAISIN IN THE
SUN OR FASTER LIKE A SORE AND
THEN RUN DOES IT STINK LIKE
ROTTEN MEAT. OR CRUST AND SUGAR
OVER. LIKE A SYRUPY SWEET.
MAYBE IT JUST SAGS LIKE A HEAVY
LOAD. OR DOES IT EXPLODE. GOD
OF MERCY AND COMPASSION IN THE
MIDST OF FAR TOO MANY BROKEN
AND DEFERRED DREAMS. WE ASK FOR
YOUR GRACE AND COURAGE TO FACE
THE INJUSTICES OF OUR TIME.
WITH INTEGRITY OF WORD INDEED
FOR THE SAKE OF THE COMMON GOOD
AND THE FUTURE OF OUR SOCIETY.
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME
COMMENT. TO OUR FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES AMERICA. REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH. YEAH THIS CALL.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA BE VAN SEEN
IN OUR CALENDAR TODAY
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR WE HAVE
NINE MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED READ. SUCH IS
FROM THE ASSEMBLY BETTER.
MISTER PREIDENT I AM DIRECTED
TO INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY
THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND
ON THIS DAY PASSED AS AMENDED
SENATE BILLS NINETY EIGHT ONE
SIXTEEN AND SENATE BILL THREE
HUNDRED AND ESPECIALLY REQUESTS
YOUR HONORABLE BODY TO CONCUR
AND SAID AMENDMENTS TO PARKER
CHIEF CLERK OF THE ASSEMBLY
ABOVE BILLS ORDER TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS FILE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM SECRETARY. WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE MOVING ON TO REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO THE- MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY ITEM NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY. YOU
MEMBERS WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
ADVANCING INTO THE
CONSIDERATION OF OUR DAILY FILE.
CENTER BRADFORD UNDER- WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS PLEASE PROCEED SIR
ARE WAS PRESENT I REQUESTED AB
SEVENTEEN OH NINE BY SOME WOMAN
JONES SAWYER AND A. B. TWELVE
NINETY NINE BY SOME LIMóN AS A
MEMBER SALAS BE REMOVED.
REMOVED FROM AN ACTIVE FILE.
THEIR REFEREE PJ DEBT THE DESK
WILL NOTE LAYS IN GENERAL THE
SENATE ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO BE REMOVED AN ITEM I'M FROM
THE FILE. HEARING SEEN NO ONE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ADVANCING
WITHIN OUR COUNTER FOR THE DAY
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
TOWARDS THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. WE'RE GONNA
START WITH THE SECOND READING
FILE ITEM SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
FIFTY. THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY WE'RE GOING TO BE
ADVANCING NOW THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS FOR THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE TURNING THE FLOOR OVER
TO SENATOR WELL. SENATOR WILK
IS GONNA BE STARTING US OUT
WITH ITEM NUMBER SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX IS A
CONFIRMATION OF CRYSTAL ANTHONY
AND JOHN SO THAT. TO THE BOARD
OF THE BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES.
LEAST SEAL TO THE BOARD OF
STATE A COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
AND KENNETH BERMAN TO THE
BOATING AND WATERWAYS
COMMISSION. IS APPOINTED
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY
UNANIMOUS VOTE WHEN THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON THE
SEVENTEENTH OF JUNE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE- WELL THANK YOU SO MCH IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR. LAST CALL DISCUSS.
HEARING XENON RANDOM SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
I ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. AYE
BELL HI FOR JUST I BRADFORD I
CUT BY ADAM. I CHIANG I DALLY.
I DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI GROWTH
HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL I WOULD
ASSUME HI TADO. I JACKSON I
JONES I LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ AYE MITCHELL. I MONEY
I MORE LOCK AYE MORALE I
NIELSEN I CAN I PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO. SKINNER HI STERN-
I NUMBER HI MY CAO SKI AYE
WIENER. HI WILK HI SURGERY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE
AYES THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
WERE NOW WILL BE NINE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN UNDER
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT SENATOR
WELL THANK YOU SIR MEMBERS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN CATALINA SEE FOR
WINTERS AND HOW IGGY AGA DOCTOR
JUDITH MAXWELL GREG FURRY
POINTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID. COMMISSION THE SO
A DINING FOR POINT TO THE
CALIFORNIA VETERANS BOARD
IMMERSE SO DILATORY AT SCHOOL
BETO FOR REFORMING TO THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING THESE APPOINTEES
WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE SEVENTEENTH
ON A FIVE A VOTE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. SENATORS
THERE ARE THERE IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SENATOR WIENER GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT EYES WHEN- BRIEFLY
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE SO WE
DUNNING'S- NOMINATION TO THE TO
THE VETERANS BOARD- I'VE KNOWN-
STORY FOR A LONG TIME SERVICES
BECAUSE SHE IS A- AN AL
LESBIAN- WHO- SERVED HONORABLY
IN THE MILITARY AND HAS BEEN A-
A TRUE LEADER AND TERMS OF
ADVANCING OUR COMMUNITY IN
GENERAL. AND SPECIFICALLY-
MAKING SURE THAT- LGBTQ PEOPLE
ARE WELCOME AND CONSERVE OPEN
THEM PROBABLY IN THE MILITARY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER WIENER ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. LAST CALL FOR SENATORS.
MADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS FIVE WELL
FIVE FOR JUST I BRADFORD I HAVE
A YELLOW. I CHIANG I DALLY I
DODD. I RISING FIVE GALGIANI I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG I HILL I HUESO. HI
TADO HI JACKSON I JONES I LEYVA
I'VE MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ AYE
MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE LOCK
I'VE BEEN AROUND. I NIELSEN. I
PAN. FIVE AYE ROTH. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. FIVE STERN. I UMBERG
HI MY CASKEY. I WIENER I WILK
HI. HIGHS THIRTY NINE NINE AYE
AYES TO BE NINE. NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO
OUR THIRD ADAM FOR GOVERNOR
APPOINTMENTS ON THE DAILY FILE
CENTER WORK ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS WELL I'M NOT
A AND NUMBER EIGHT IS A
CONFIRMATION OF DIANA PRIOR
LOVE JAMES RULAND MERRY TANKER
TO THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD. CHARLES BONHAM
AND BARBARA AND LEE TO THE
PACIFIC STATES MARINA FISHERIES
COMMISSION IN AND SAY CISNEROS
AND CHRIS FOR YOU GOING TO SAY
TO THE STATE BAR BOARD OF
TRUSTEES THESE APPOINTEES WERE
APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS VOTE IN
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
JUNE SEVENTEENTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER WILK LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. HEARING
SEEN NONE OF SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BELL. I
FORGES AYE BRADFORD HI COME BY
ADAM HI CHIANG I DALLY HI DODD.
I TORONTO HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG HI HELLO. I WISH SO.
I HER TADO HI JACKSON I JONES I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S I
MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE LOCK
I RURAL. I NIELSEN I PAN I
PORTANTINO HI ROTH I RUBIO.
I'VE SKINNER. I STERN HI I'M
BURKE I LIKE HOW TO SKI. HI
WIENER HI WILK HI. SIZE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE POINT IS
CONFIRM. MEMBERS ARE NOT GONNA
BE MOVING ON TO OUR LAST ITEM
UNDER GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
CENTER WILL THANKS FOR YOUR
WORK TODAY THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
IS A CONFIRMATION OF PHIL
GINSBURG FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
STATE PARK AND RECREATION
COMMISSION. AND DAVID CARILLO
ENACT ANNA COULD THIS VICTOR
KING AND JIM MCALISTER AND
RICHARD SIMPSON TO THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION THESE APPOINTEES
WERE PROVIDE RULES COMMITTEE ON
THE SEVENTY TWO JUNE ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR AN AYE VOTE. IGGY
CENTER WILL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR THIRTY
LEADER HERTZBERG THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR. THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
MISSED PRESIDENT I COULD NOT TO
GET THIS OPPORTUNITY TALK ABOUT
RICK SIMPSON. EIGHTY SERVE NINE
SPEAKERS AND AS HE TEXTED ME HE
SAID TWO OF THOSE SPEAK THE TWO
BEST SPEAKERS YOU WORK FOR HERE
ON THIS FLOOR HERE TODAY MADAM
PRO TEM. AND HE HE WAS A- IS AN
INTERESTING FELLOW HE IS THE
AUTHOR OF ROAD MAP TO PEACE IN
OUR TIME AND ONLY A FEW PEOPLE
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS. IS A
CHAMPIONSHIP FENCER HE IS NOT A
LAWYER AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
THIS IS THE VERY IMPORTANT LAW
REVISION COMMISSION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE IN
THE PUT NON LAWYER ON IT IS
PROBABLY NOT SUCH A WISE THING
BUT AS WE BEGIN TO REFLECT A
LITTLE BIT. HE IS A FELLOW WHO
PROBABLY WROTE MORE BALLS THAN
ANY LAWYER WHO CITY CALIFORNIA
IT IS TURN YEAR OF THE NINE
SPEAKERS WITH WHOM WE WORK FOR
INCLUDING THE CDA AS A SENIOR
STAFFER SO I I'M DEBATING
WHETHER OR NOT CHOOSE TO STAND
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
MISTER SIMPSON BUT I THINK
THAT- HIS SKILL AND-
UNBELIEVABLE ABILITY OR DRAFT
LAWS IS A PERFECT POSITION FOR
HIM. AND I STRONGLY STAND IN
SUPPORT OF OUR DEAR FRIEND RICK
SIMPSON. THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU
MISTER MAJORITY LEADER MEMBERS
WE HAVE TWO SENATORS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO SPEAK WE'RE
GONNA GO TO SENATOR WIENER AND
INTO SENATOR AWESOME CENTER
WIENER. FORESHORES THANK YOU
RESERVE RESIDENT ON I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF. UNTIL GINSBURG FOR
THE STATE OF PARKING
RECOGNITION BY MR GINSBURG IS
THE GENERAL MANAGER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO. A RECREATION AND
PARKS DEPARTMENT HE HAS BEEN-
FOR ABOUT A DECADE- HE HAS A
THROUGH HIS INCREDIBLE
LEADERSHIP AND TO NOT CITY-
HELP TO REALLY MODERNIZE AND
TRANSFORM. OUR PART IS DONE ON
THE THOUGHT OF THE RENOVATING
AN OPERATING A VERY OLD AND
EXPANSIVE SYSTEM- HE'S DONE
EXTRAORDINARY WORK HE'S A
VISIONARY AND I THINK- THE
STATUS OF THE- VERY FORTUNATE.
TO HAVE CONSERVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR WIENER PLACE IN
GERMAN THAT'S RECOGNIZED DRAWS
A- THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT-
I JUST STAND UP. TO SPEAK BACK
IN SO STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF ON
A GROUP OF US SHE HAS BEEN A
VERY STRONG ADVOCATE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY FROM THE CENTRAL
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. THE BROADER
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY OFF AND ON
WOMEN'S ISSUES THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING ABOUT ON A IS
THAT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT HER
SHE PUTS A LOT INTO HELPING
OTHER WOMEN- AND OTHER
IMMIGRANTS STRIVE TO BE. MORE
EFFECTIVE AND STRONGER LEADERS
IN OUR COMMUNITY SO I'M VERY
PROUD THAT SHE WILL BE UP GIVEN
THIS UP POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
EISELE. GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S
RECOGNIZE SENATOR RUBIO. MISTER
PRESIDENT I ALSO WANT TO ADD MY
VOICE AND- ECHO WHAT YEAH THE
GREAT CENTER FROM LOS ANGELES
SAID ABOUT ANNAPOLIS AND I HAS
BEEN SUCH AN ADVOCATE FOR OUR
YOUNG LADIES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY LET THE MASS HE'S
BEEN A MENTOR HAS PUT A LOT OF
MENTORSHIP PROGRAMS. OFF FOR
AGAIN NOT JUST LETTING US BUT
OUR YOUTH AND GENERAL AND SUCH
AN OUTSTANDING MEMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY SO I ALSO WITH THEM I
OFFER MY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO.
BASINGER IN THE SENATE ANY
ADDITIONAL THE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CENTER AMBER. I THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION OF THE- IF
WE CAN HAVE A HIGH TWENTY
SECOND CENTER BRING THIS MAKE
SURE YOUR MIKE IS UP AND
RUNNING. THAT'S RIGHT AGAIN
CENTER BURDEN A QUESTION OF THE
PROPONENTS. SO TO. CENTER WILK
I HEARD SENATOR HERTZBERG SAY
THAT. THE TWO BEST SPEAKERS OF
MISTER SIMPSON WORK FOR ON THE
FLOOR I SEE CENTER AT CONSUME
ANY IDEA WHO THE OTHER ONE WAS.
CENTER WHAT WE ACCEPT THE
QUESTION. THE PLEASURE. PLEASE
PROCEED CENTER WILL. CENTERED I
MEAN- SPEAKER JOHN PEREZ
BECAUSE HE WAS MY FIRST SPEAKER
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
CENTER WILL FOR THE SAVE THANK
YOU SO MUCH- CENTER WELL THANK
YOU CENTER ON BURKE.
DISTINGUISHED SENATORS ANY
ADDITIONAL THE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. LAST CALL
FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. GIVE US A MOMENT PLEASE.
BETTER SECONDARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I TELL. FIVE FOR JUST I
BRADFORD HI CABRERA I CHIANG
AYE DALLY I DODD. I DRAWS THEM
I GALGIANI I GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG AYE HILL I HUESO. HI
LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S.
I MITCHELL. HI MONNING I MORE
LOCK HIGH MORALE I NIELSEN HI
PAM I PORTANTINO. HI ROSS I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN I AM
BURKE HI MY COUNTY I WIENER. I
WILK. HI HI. THIRTY NINE ZERO
ZERO APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
THE DAILY FILE UNDER UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WE HAVE FOUR FILE
ITEMS ARE GOING TO BE IN FRONT
OF US LAYS ENGINE THE SENATE
YOU SHOULD HAVE ALL RECEIVED A
SUBLIMINAL FILE THAT IS ON YOUR
DESK SUBLIMINAL FILE THAT IS ON
YOUR DESK. WE'RE GONNA BE
TAKING UP FILE ITEM. THIRTY TWO
THIRTY THREE THIRTY FOUR. AND
THIRTY FIVE. FOR NOW CAN BE
MOVING ON TO OUR FIRST ITEM OF
BUSINESS THE UNFINISHED
BUSINESS PORTION CENTER
MITCHELL PREPARED TO RESENTMENT
OF SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINETY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACTUAL LEADING TO
EDUCATION FINANCE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. META BUDGET
YEARS SOONER MITCHELL THE FLOOR
IS YOURS I APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT HAPPY
MONDAY- TO ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES. SENATE BILL NINETY
EIGHT IS THE EDUCATION ON THIS
TRAILER BILL AND CONTAIN
STATUTORY CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE IN THE
FOYER REDUCTIONS TO KATIE
TWELVE EDUCATION AND INSTEAD
DIFFERS. A TOTAL OF ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN PRINCIPLE
APPORTIONMENT PAYMENTS THE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES FROM
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEAR. TO THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FISCAL YEAR THESE DEFERRALS
WILL BE REDUCED TO THE EXTENT.
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE RECEIVED. IT
PROVIDES FOR A HOLD HARMLESS
FOR AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
FOR PURPOSES OF KP TWELVE
APPORTIONMENT. AND THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR. DEFINES
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR OFFERING
DISTANCE LEARNING AND REQUIRES
A LEARNING CAN CONTINUITY IN
ATTENDANCE PLAN IN PLACE OF THE
LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR.
IT APPROPRIATES FIVE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING. TO ADDRESS
LEARNING LOSS IN OTHER IMPACTS
OF COAL THAT NINETEEN OF THIS
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION IS
DISTRIBUTED BASED ON THE
ENROLLMENT OF STUDENTS WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS. TWO POINT
NINE BILLION IS DISTRIBUTED IN
PROPORTION TO A LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY SHARE OF SUPPLEMENTAL
AND CONCENTRATION FUNDS AND
NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION IS
DISTRIBUTED IN PROPORTION TO AN
ALLEY A SHARE OF TOTAL LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA FOR FUN
FUNDS. THE PREVENT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FROM LAYING OFF
TEACHERS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FISCAL YEAR. INCLUDES
INTENT LANGUAGE THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND JOINT POWER
AUTHORITIES DO NOT LAY OFF
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR
AND PREVENTS CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WHO HOLD POSITIONS
THE NUTRITION. TRANSPORTATION
AND CUSTODIAL SERVICES FROM
BEING TERMINATED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR. EARLY
EDUCATION AND CHILD
DEVELOPMENT. ITS STABILIZERS
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR
BY HOLDING PROVIDERS HARMLESS
FOR CHANGES IN THE TENDONS AND
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL STIPEND
FUNDING. IT PROVIDES SEVENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS TO CONTINUE
TEMPORARY CHILD CARE FOR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND AT RISK
CHILDREN FURTHER INSURANCE
PRIORITY FOR THESE CHILDREN IN
ENTERING PERMANENT CARE. IT
SPECIFIES THAT ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE RECEIVED FOR
CHILDCARE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEAR THOSE FUNDS WILL BE
PRIORITIZE FOR INCREASING
ACCESS TO CARE RECENT TO
WORKERS AND OTHERS WE OPENING
GRANTS AN ADDITIONAL FIVE. IT
SHIFTS CHILDCARE PROGRAMS WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
COMMENCING JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WITH REGARD TO
SECTION THIRTY FOUR OF THE BILL
WITH REGARD TO- THE EIGHTY A
HOLD HARMLESS LANGUAGE LET ME
SAY THIS. THE BILL FUNDS ALL
EARLY EIGHTIES. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
USING THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
COUNTS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEAR. ALL SCHOOLS
INCLUDING CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
TREATED THE SAME. THE ONE
EXCEPTION IS NEW CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHO DID NOT HAVE ABA IN
THE NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR. THESE
SCHOOLS ARE FUNDED USING A
PROXY FOR EIGHTY EIGHT BASED ON
ACTUAL ENROLLMENT FOR CURRENT
PRACTICE WITH NEW CHARTER
SCHOOLS. SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS
HAVE STRESSED HOW CRITICAL
AREAS FOR TENDED TO BE HELD
HARMLESS IN THE UPCOMING SCHOOL
YEAR BECAUSE WE KNOW DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC MANY STUDENTS WILL BE
OUT OF CLASS AT VARIOUS POINTS
IN THE YEAR AND SCHOOLS MAY
HAVE TO CLOSE DUE TO FUTURE
OUTBREAKS. HOLDING EIGHTY EIGHT
AT THE NINETEEN TWENTY LEVEL
PROVIDE STABILITY TO ELLIE ACE
FOR THE PURPOSES OF BUDGETING
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
YEARS. THIS MEANS THAT ABA
GROWTH IS NOT FUNDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR.
DUE TO THE DROP IN STATE
REVENUES THE STATE CAN'T AFFORD
TO INCREASE BILL SIAPA. THE
BULL HOLD ONLY A FARMERS FOR
ATTENDANCE UNCERTAINTY DO THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC AND FUN
GROW. OTHERWISE THE STATE COULD
BE FACED WITH MID YEAR CUTS TO
SCHOOLS OR LARGER DEFERRALS IN
THE STATE IS ALREADY DIFFERENT
MORE FUNDS FOR SCHOOLS THAN IT
DID IN THE LAST RECESSION. IN
ADDITION DUE TO THE POTENTIAL
OF DISTANCE LEARNING IT'S
DIFFICULT TO ACCURATELY TRACK
EIGHTY EIGHT IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR. LIKE
MANY OF YOU WE HAVE HEARD
CONCERNS FROM CHARTER SCHOOLS
TO ANTICIPATE SIGNIFICANT
GROWTH IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE DUE
TO PARENTS CHOOSING TO MOVE
STUDENTS THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND FROM
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE IN AREAS
WITH GROWING POPULATIONS. GIVEN
THE DIFFERENCES IN HOW
INSTRUCTION MAY BE PROVIDED
THIS YEAR AND THE NEED FOR
FLEXIBILITY PAIRED WITH LIMITED
FUNDING. THIS IS A REASONABLE
POLICY THAT PROVIDES FISCAL
STABILITY TO THE ALLEY ACE.
THERE ARE SOME ELEAZAR
INCLUDING CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
MAY RECEIVE LESS HEALTHY
AFFECTED ANTICIPATED THIS YEAR.
HOWEVER KATIE TWELVE EDUCATION
IS RECEIVING FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDS ABOVE
EL CFM. THE HELP WITH THE
IMPACT OF COLD IT. TO HELP WITH
THE IMPACT OF COLD WITH. WITH
THAT WITH THE PRESIDENT I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SB NINETY
EIGHT CENTER WHICH WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK BUDGET
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS
DOCUMENT AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO BE A TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS CENTER
NIELSEN FLOORS OR SIR. THIS
PRESIDENT LAYS DOWN THE SENATE
I HAVE TO SOMEWHAT RELUCTANTLY
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. IT DOES CAPTION
CHARTER SCHOOLS FOR. AND
THERE'S IN MY OPINION HALF A
REASON BEHIND IT THAT RELATES
TO SOME OF THE- ADVOCATES FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. AND I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD DISADVANTAGE
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS BECAUSE
THEY MAY BE GAINING ENROLLMENT.
IN THIS ALSO CAPS GROWTH
FUNDING FOR BOTH. THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THE WHEN THEY HAVE INCREASED
ENROLLMENT. PRIOR IN PRIOR TO
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY SO IT TO
A DEGREE WELL. DISADVANTAGED
SOME PUBLIC SCHOOLS NOT NOT A
LOT INDEED BUT SOME. AND THAT
PROVISION ITSELF I THINK IS
CAUSE FOR CONCERN. AND I
TRUSTED YOU'LL LIKE MYSELF WERE
INUNDATED BY CALLS FROM CHARTER
SCHOOL FAMILIES. WHO ENJOY THIS
EDUCATION AND KNOWLEDGE BEING
HELPFUL TO THEIR CHILDREN AND
THEY WERE VERY ALARMED AN
AGGRIEVED TO FIND THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO. THE DISADVANTAGE
YET AGAIN I ORIGINAL OF. THANK
YOU SIR NIELSEN MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE WE HAVE SEVERAL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO SPEAK THIS AFTERNOON WE'RE
GONNA GO NEXT TO LEADER GROW
INTO CENTER PORTANTINO SENATOR
CHIANG SENATOR GLAZER IN CENTER
RUBIO LEADER GROVE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL I DO APPRECIATE THE AT
BUDGET'S HERE MAKING SURE THAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC
SCHOOLS WERE TREATED THE SAME-
I DO REQUEST THOUGH BECAUSE WE
DO NEED TO LOOK AT SOME THINGS
DIFFERENTLY. FOR INSTANCE GREEN
WAY SCHOOLS IN OUR DISTRICT
KERN COUNTY IS A TWO TIER
SCHOOL CHARTER NETWORK SERVING
COMMUNITIES IN ARVIN AND
SHAFTER. IN THE SOUTHERN PART
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY NOW
ALTHOUGH I REPRESENT A LARGE
SWATH OF KERN COUNTY THESE
PARTICULAR LOCATIONS IN
MAJORITY MINORITY FARMING
COMMUNITIES. ARE REPRESENTED BY
MY COLLEAGUE WHO SHARES KERN
COUNTY WITH ME. THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OF CALIFORNIA IS THE
FASTEST GROWING REGION IN THE
ENTIRE STATE. KERN COUNTY WERE
GRIMLY SCHOOLS IS LOCATED AT
THE HIGHEST INCREASE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR TOTAL
NUMBER OF SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
BASED ON THE MOST RECENT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REPORTING.
IN THESE MAJORITY LET FARMING
COMMUNITIES NO THERE CHILDREN
ARE RIDING IN THIS EXCELLENT
CHARTER- ENVIRONMENT THAT
GRAHAM WAY PER FOUGHT PROVIDES.
AND THE CAP ON THE SCHOOL
GROWTH FUNDING IN SB NINETY
EIGHT WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANTLY
DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS ON THE
SCHOOL YEAR FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET. AND AT GROOM WAIT
ACADEMY SPECIFICALLY IN SHAFTER
WHICH AGAIN IS A MAJORITY
MINORITY FARMING COMMUNITY.
GREENWAY SCHOOLS POSITION
APPROVED- THIS PETITION
APPROVED BY RICHMOND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AUTHORIZED
OPENING THIS SCHOOL YEAR THE US
OPEN IN THE SCHOOL WITH KATIE
THROUGH FOURTH GRADE AND ADDING
AN ADDITIONAL GRADE LEVEL EVERY
YEAR AFTER THAT UNTIL THEY
REACH THE EIGHTH GRADE. LEVEL
AND IF THE CAPRI MEANS IN SB
NINETY EIGHT THEY TEND TO LOSE
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RAP
REVENUE- IN STATE FUNDING FOR
THEIR SCHOOLS WHICH EQUATES AND
SHE AFTER A LOAN OF JUST ABOUT
10% OF THEIR OPERATING BUDGET.
THIS WILL NOT ALLOW THEM TO
CONTINUE TO OPEN THOSE HIGHER
GRADE LEVELS AT TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY WHO IS
DESIRING TO HAVE THEIR CHILDREN
GET A BETTER EDUCATION- THAN
WHAT THEY WERE GETTING IN
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THIS THE FOR THIS FORCE THEM TO
MAKE EXCEEDINGLY DIFFICULT
BUDGETARY DECISIONS IN THE
UPCOMING SCHOOL YEAR- I WOULD
ASK THAT THE STATE DEVELOP A
FUNCTION TO ALLOW THE ELEAZAR.
TO ALLOW LEDS WITH GROWING
ENROLLMENT FROM PUBLIC AND IN
PUBLIC AND CHARTER SCHOOLS- ALL
THE NUMBERS POINT ESPECIALLY IN
THESE MAJORITY MINORITY
DISTRICTS. WHERE FAMILIES ARE
TRADITIONALLY STUCK IN A ZIP
CODE- THESE SCHOOLS ARE
ACTUALLY IN THESE DISTRICTS AND
PROVIDING A BETTER QUALITY
EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS AND
THEIR EXCEED THEIR EXCEEDING
VERY WELL. IN GOING TO COLLEGE
AND COLLEGE PREP CLASSES- IN
KEEPING WITH THE SPIRIT OF PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND EIGHT EIGHT
SEVENTEEN. I BEGAN YOUR ZIP
CODE SHOULD NOT REQUIRE YOU TO
STAND LOW PERFORMING SCHOOLS
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE A TO
THIS ISUE WITH GROWING
STUDENTS GROWING- AND PARENTS
GROWING TO HAVE THEIR STUDENTS
GO TO A PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AND I WOULD ASK CONSIDERATION
FOR THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMMENTS
ARE NOT GOING TO GO TO CENTER
PORTANTINO THE NEW CENTER
CHANGE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS- I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY EIGHT.
TODAY AND I HAVE TO COMPLEMENT
OUR BUDGET CHAIR- AND OUR
BUDGET SUB ONE CHAIR AS WELL
FOR THEIR WORK ON PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND OF COURSE. THE
PRO TEM IN THE SENATE TO TEAM-
I CAN'T TELL A LIE BUT I WAS
SCARED THIS YEAR- THAT WE WORK
IN A HOLD THE LINE ON EDUCATION
FUNDING FOR THOSE OF US WHO
WERE HERE BACK DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION- EDUCATION. ROUTINELY
GOT CUT WITHOUT MUCH THOUGHT
WITHOUT MUCH PRIORITY TO SOLVE
THE BUDGET CRISIS BACK THEN IT
WAS DIFFICULT FOLKS WHO GOT UP
AND TALKED ABOUT EDUCATION AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF FINDING THAT
GENERATIONS FUTURE- DIDN'T WIN
THE CONVERSATION- AND SO THIS
YEAR WHEN WE CAME OUT WITH A
STRONG STATEMENT ON EDUCATION I
WAS OF COURSE SUPPORTIVE OF IT
BUT I WAS ALWAYS WORRIED THAT
IN THE DAY- AT THE END OF THE
DAY EDUCATION WOULD SUFFER. AND
I'M PROUD THAT THE SENATE
BUDGET ARCHITECTURE ONE THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT WAS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO AND SO I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
EIGHT OF COURSE THERE ARE
THINGS IN A BUDGET TRAILER BILL
THAT THE NO NO SENATOR NOBODY.
APPRECIATES AND A PROVES OF
EVERY SINGLE. NOT A SOUL OF
SOMETHING THIS COMPLEX IN THIS
LARGE BUT OVERALL THE FACT THAT
STABILITY. BECAME THE MANTRA
THAT IT WAS WE KNOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE SIGNIFICANT.
DECISIONS TO BE MADE NEXT YEAR
AND HOW WE FIND GOVERNMENT HOW
WE FIND EDUCATION BUT THIS YEAR
WE CHOSE TO USE STABILITY. AS
OUR OVERRIDING PRINCIPLE WAS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO YOU NEVER
WANT TO SAY TO A SCHOOL THAT IS
DRAWING MORE STUDENTS THAT IS
IMPROVING- ITS ATTENDANCE
NUMBERS THAT PEOPLE WANT TO GO.
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
RECOGNIZE THE ROLE THAT SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE INCREASE ENROLLMENT
HAVE- YOU KNOW THAT'S A TOUGH
MESSAGE TO SAY TO SCHOOLS THAT
ARE DOING WELL- BUT I THINK WE
ALSO HAVE TO SAY. WE HEAR THAT
WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE
DEPRECIATE THAT AND LONG TERM
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT IN A
WHY ARE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
MOVING FROM RUN SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO ANOTHER. THAT'S A VALID
QUESTION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO ADDRESS I ALSO THINK
WE HAVE TO TAKE THIS TIME OF
COVE IT. COULD LOOK AT HOW WE
FUND EDUCATION IS USING AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE THE RIGHT
FORMULA SHOULD WE BE LOOKING AT
NEW MODELS. POST CODE VISIT
WITH THEIR SPLIT DAYS AND
ENROLLMENT- DIFFERENCES ON
MONDAY VERSES WEDNESDAY VERSUS
FRIDAY WE HAVE TO BE CREATIVE
AND THIS IS THE TIME TO DO IT
SO ALL OF THOSE IDEAS. THAT
HAVE BEEN PROPOSED TO REIMAGINE
PUBLIC EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
THIS IS THE TIME TO DO THAT RE
IMAGINING THIS IS THE TIME
BETWEEN THIS YEAR AND NEXT
YEAR. TO COME UP WITH FUNDING
MODELS THAT MEET. A TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY EDUCATION SYSTEM
AND NOT SOMETHING THAT WAS
CREATED IN THE NINETEEN FIFTIES
WHEN WE WERE A FARMING IN
MANUFACTURING ECONOMY. THIS IS
THE TIME TO REIMAGINE IT AND
THIS IS THE TIME FRANKLY TO
INVEST IN IT THIS YEAR WE HAD
TO STABILIZE THE SYSTEM. AND I
THINK WE DID THAT MUCH BETTER
THAN I WOULD HAVE IMAGINED TWO
MONTHS AGO AND AGAIN I
COMPLEMENT OUR LEADERSHIP FOR
MAKING THAT HAPPEN. AND I SAY
TO ALL OF OUR EDUCATION
ADVOCATES IN FUHRMAN'S WE HEAR
YOU THAT ARCH IN MATTER. AND
HOPEFULLY WILL SPEND THIS TIME
TO REIMAGINE THEIR FUTURE AND
HOW WE FUND THEIR FUTURE BETTER
THAN WE ARE DOING IN THE PAST
OR HAVE DONE IN THE PAST DECADE
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. AN
AYE VOTE ON SB NINETY EIGHT
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO
LADIES AND GERMS SENATE REGULAR
CENTER CHIANG CENTER GLAZER.
CENTER RUBIO AND SENATOR
STERN'S CHAIN GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MISTER. MEMBERS FOR
SOMEONE TO SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE THE OF THE BY CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE.
UNFORTUNATELY I MUST RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. IT IS FRUSTRATING
TO SEE THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE US
TODAY AS IT SEEKS OUT THE
STUDENTS MOST IN NEED. AND THEN
FREEZES THEM OUT OF THE BUDGET.
PARENTS HAVE BEEN CALLING MY
OFFICE PLEADING PLEASE DON'T
PASS THIS BILL. I REALLY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE. LAST WEEK WE PASSED A
BILL THAT WOULD MOVE FROM THE
CONSTITUTION OF PROHIBITION ON
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION IN STATE
GOVERNMENT. AND THIS WEEK WE'RE
PULLING THE RUG OUT FROM
UNDERNEATH MINORITY STUDENTS.
SOME OF THESE CALLS ARE
LIFELINE FOR LOW INCOME
MINORITY AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. OF SCHOOLS IN
ROMAN IS OFTEN GROWING AS A
FUNCTION OF HOW WELL THE
EDUCATE THEIR KIDS. DESPERATE
PARENTS FIND THE SCHOOL SO
THEIR CHILDREN HAVE A SHOT AT A
GOOD EDUCATION. THIS BILL IS
TURNING THOSE PARENTS AND THEIR
KIDS AWAY WHAT ARE WE DOING
HERE. I GET IT OUR ECONOMY HAS
TAKEN A SEVERE HIT FROM THE
PANDEMIC AND THAT WILL MEAN
SOME CUTS BUT PLEASE DON'T
TARGET THE STUDENTS. FIND THE
SAVINGS ELSEWHERE THESE KIDS
NEED OUR SUPPORT NOW MORE THAN
EVER. IF WE WANT EQUALITY UNDER
THE LAW TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL
THIS BILL IS REALLY LACKING
EMPATHY MEMBERS LET'S GO BACK
TO THE DRAWING BOARD I ORIGINAL.
YOU SAID. FIRST REMEMBER.
CENTER GLAZER FOR HIS RESEARCH.
THANK YOU OF THIS PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I JOIN AND- EXPRESSING
MY APPRECIATION TO THE BUDGET
CHAIR AND SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR
AND ALL MEMBERS WHO WORKED SO
HARD ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
EDUCATION WE KNOW IT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE DO IS A
STATE. IT IS PROBABLY THE MOST
CHALLENGING TIME FOR US AND FOR
OUR EDUCATION LEADERS FROM
AROUND OUR STATE BOARD MEMBERS
AND SUPERINTENDENTS HAVE CALLED
MY OFFICE I'M SURE THEY'VE
CALLED YOURS- THIS MEASURE HAS
SEVENTY EIGHT DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS AND- MOST OF THE MICE
I AGREE WITH AND A FEW THAT I
DON'T. BUT ON BALANCE I KNOW
THAT OUR- LEADERS HAVE AS THE
STRIVEN TO. CREATE THE- A
BALLOT IT TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
AND I THINK THIS BILL DOES DO
THAT I WON A RECORD THE
COMMENTS FROM THE SENATOR FROM
SACRAMENTO IN THE SENATOR FROM
RIVERSIDE DURING THE BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS. ON THIS BILL AND
IN PARTICULAR ON THE HOLD
HARMLESS ISSUE IT IS A PROBLEM
FOR MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS WHERE
THERE HAS BEEN ENROLLMENT
GROWTH FVE THREE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- THAT THAT. ENJOYED
GROWTH FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS
LIVERMORE VALLEY. JOINT UNIFIED
BRENT WOODS ELEMENTARY IN
DUBLIN UNIFIED. THEY HAVE
PLANNED FOR THIS GROWTH. A
HIRED STAFF FOR THIS GROWTH.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE BALANCING
THAT'S IN THE BILL TODAY- IS
GOING TO PENALIZE THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE ENJOYED
THAT GROWTH BUT I RECOGNIZE.
THAT IN MANY WAYS THIS BUDGET
SITUATION COULD HAVE BEEN SO
MUCH WORSE. AND I FEAR AS THE
SENATOR FROM. BLOCKING YACHT I
INDICATED THAT AS YOU LOOK TO
THE FUTURE OF THESE BUDGETS FOR
OUR SCHOOLS MAY GET EVEN MORE
CHALLENGING SO DESPITE SOME
DIFFERENCES IN THIS PARTICULAR
BILL I'M- I AM I. GOING TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER GLAZER
NOT GONNA RECOGNIZE RUBIO.
THREATENING CENTER. THANK YOU
MISS PRESIDENT AND CALL A I'LL-
OF RICE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
OF FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THIS WAS NOT AN EASY. EASY
DECISION BUT I ALSO WANT TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORDS OF MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM LOCKING OUT A
WHO STATED THAT STABILITY IN
THESE TIMES UNCERTAIN TIMES IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT. AND I
WANT TO SHARE THAT I WAS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER WHEN THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT CUTS CAME. YOUR
AND IT WAS SO DEVASTATING NOT
ONLY TO OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITY
ARE COMMUNITY SAID THAT IN
LARGE BUT ALSO A TRICKLE DOWN
TO OUR STUDENTS. COLLECTIVELY
ARE SCORES DROPPED AND SO THAT
JUST HIGH LIGHTS HOW IT DOES
DIRECTLY IMPACT OUR STUDENTS.
BUT I ALSO DON'T WANT TO MISS
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SAY TO ALL
THE TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS ARE
SUPPORT STAFF. TAKE ON A TO
EVERYONE THAT'S HOW TO
SACRIFICE DURING THIS TIME.
THAT WE ARE SO THANKFUL THAT
YOU STEPPED UP. REMOTE LEARNING
IS NOT EASY IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT TEACHERS ARE PREPARED TO
DO. AND DOT AND I FIVE REMEMBER
THE TEACHER WE WERE NEVER
TRAINED SELL FOR ALL THOSE
TEACHERS OUT THERE. THERE ARE
STEPPING UP AND DOING THE WORK
WEEK THANK YOU. BUT AGAIN I
WANT TO USE TO SAY THAT
STABILITY WAS IMPORTANT. AND SO
I DO RIGHT TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE THERE'S- AT LEAST A LOT
OF THINGS THAT. I THINK IS
ESSENTIAL- IN PARTICULAR EVERY
JACK'S THE MAY REVISE. FIGURE
CUTS TO CHILD CARE PROGRAMS IT
DOES FUND BOB K. THROUGH
TWELVE. AND THE ONE TIME FUNDS
AT FIVE POINT THREE MILLION TO
AT LEAST COVER AND TRY TO
MINUTE MITIGATE SOME OF THE-
THE ACT GAPS IN EDUCATION DUE
TO CALL THAT IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT. I KNOW ONCE STUDENT
BEHIND STILL DIFFICULT TO CLOSE
THAT A- GAP. AGAIN COLLEAGUES.
ASK FOR YOUR BIBLE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. TWENTY SO MUCH WE'RE NOT
TO GO TO SENATOR. AND SENATOR
MORLOCK GOOD AFTERNOON TO
RESTORE. FLOORS. BUT AFTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR PRESIDENT. I
READ IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
AND WANT TO GIVE US A SLIGHTLY
FOR THAN IT THE ONE WE'VE SO
FAR AND DOES I SHARE THE OF
MIKE. IN THE IN THE WORK FROM
OUR SENATE LEADERSHIP AND FOR
LEADING ALL THE WAY IN TO MAKE
PUBLIC EDUCATION. A CENTRAL
PRIORITY IN THIS BUDGET AND-
THE FRAMEWORK IS SOLID- WE'VE
MADE PROGRESS HERE AND WE COULD
NOT HAVE DONE THAT WITHOUT THE
ADAM INSTEAD- WE CAN'T LET OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COLLAPSE IN
THIS CRISIS- HAVING JUST GOT
OFF THE PHONE WITH A NUMBER OF
MY SUPERINTENDENTS GO BOARD
MEMBERS TEACHERS CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ARE TRYING TO PLAN IN
THE NEXT. TWO WEEKS BROWSE
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL THIS FALL THEY'RE IN
A BIT OF AN IMPOSSIBLE
SITUATION- AND I WOULD JUST I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT- WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING THIS HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION AND REALLY
FOCUSING ON THIS QUESTION OF.
NEW SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH.
INCREASED ENROLLMENT AT THE
UNCERTAINTY CLOUDING THIS
SCHOOL YEAR WILL REALLY REQUIRE
US TO TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AND
LOOK AT THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO SCHOOL YEAR. AND REALLY
THAT THREE YEAR PLANNING
HORIZON AND SAY. WE MAY HAVE TO
ACTUALLY HOLD FOLKS HARMLESS
FOR LONGER THAN THIS I DON'T
WANT US TO LIMP INTO THIS VOTE-
THIS KIND OF. EFFORT TO DEAL
WITH THE UNCERTAINTY AND BUILD
THAT INTO THE FORMULA I THINK
IS REALLY CRUCIAL RIGHT NOW AND
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE NOT
ONLY TAKE A LOOK AT. EXPANDING
UPON IT BUT REALLY TRYING TO
DEAL WITH THE UNDERLYING. GRAY
AREAS THAT ARE SET FORTH IN IN
IN THIS BILL AND TRY TO GET
SOME ADDITIONAL CLARITY FOR OUR
OUR OUR SCHOOL PUBLIC SCHOOL.
LEADERS AROUND THE STATE ARE
SPECIFICALLY THE REQUIREMENT
THAT- I BELIEVE THAT THE BILL
SAYS. A SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
ELLIE ETS- SHALL REQUIRE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION TO THE
MAXIMUM EXTENT FEASIBLE. AT IT
THAT'S THE SORT OF END OF THE
SENTENCE. BUT WHAT IS TO THE
MAXIMUM EXTENT FEASIBLE WHAT
KIND OF GUIDANCE ARE WE GIVING
THEM WHAT LIABILITY FRAMEWORK
ARE THE OPERATING WITHIN- TO
ACHIEVE THAT MAXIMUM EXTENT. WE
NEED TO GIVE MORE TOOLS TO OUR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS NOT JUST
CAST HIS VOTE AND DO THIS
TREMENDOUS BUDGET ACTION BUT
TAKE THAT NEXT STEP TO WRITING
CLARITY WE CAN'T JUST PUT UP
OUR HANDS NAY IT NOW AND SAY
THE JOB IS DONE SO. I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
MEASURE AND ALL THE HARD WORK
FROM OUR OUR SENATE TEEN- BUT I
WE GOTTA KEEP GOING FURTHER
BECAUSE IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
PLAN. IN THIS UNCERTAIN BUDGET
DYNAMIC WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL CLARITY
SO THAT. FAMILY AND PARENTS AND
KIDS KNOW WHAT IT IS THEY'RE
EVEN GOING BACK TO IN REALLY A
MATTER OF WEEKS HERE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMERCENTRE STERN WERE NOT
ENTERED OVER TO CENTER MORLOCK
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT- COLLEAGUES
RECESSIONS ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS
THIS IS A TOUGH TIME. WHAT A
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT NEED
TO BE MADE. AT THURSDAY EVENING
THE TWENTY FIFTH BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE HER
CALLERS INTO THE LATE HOURS OF
THE NIGHT. THE PREDOMINANT
TOPIC. ADDRESS WAS THEN AB
SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH IS THE-
SAME BILL AS SB NINETY EIGHT
WITH MINOR DIFFERENCES. ABOUT
WHY WERE THEY CALLING BECAUSE
HUNDREDS OF PARENTS WANT TO
TRANSFER THEIR KIDS TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AND AB SEVENTY SEVEN
PREVENTS THEM FROM TAKING NEW
STUDENTS. NOW KNOWN AS THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION. I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR OF. THE
SENATE BUDGET IN THIS REVIEW.
COMMITTEE TAKING SOME TIME
TODAY ON THE FLOOR TO EXPLAIN
THIS PARTICULAR- PROVISION- AND
TO EXPLAIN THE ADA CAP THE
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE. THE
TERM WIFE FREEZE ATTENDANCE
COUNTS. FOR PARTICULAR SCHOOLS
VERSUS DISTRICT WIDE- MAYBE I'M
MISUNDERSTANDING SOMETHING A
COUPLE THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE
IN OUR RESEARCH OF THE NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IS WE FOUND DOING
REGRESSION ANALYSIS THAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS WERE NOT
HURTING DISTRICTS FINANCIALLY
IF THEY HAD CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
TWO WE HAVE A LOT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
DROPPING IN ENROLLMENT. SO
THEREFORE IF ONE SCHOOL IN THE
DISTRICT DROPS TWENTY STUDENTS
AND THOSE TWENTY STUDENTS GO TO
THE CHARTER SCHOOL THE NET
ENROLLMENT IS THE SAME AND SO
MAYBE WE COULD HAVE AN
EXPLANATION AS TO ARE WE ARE WE
USING SINGULAR WORDS- PLURAL
WORDS FENCING CHARTER SCHOOL
SINGULAR I'M SEEING CHARTER
DISCAL DISTRICTS PLURAL AND
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFICULT TO-
UNDERSTAND BUT- IF PARENTS ARE
OUR CUSTOMERS. AND MANY IN OUR
STATE WANT AND DESIRE CHOICE WE
SHOULD NOT BE LOCKING THE DOORS
AND WE SHOULD BE TRYING TO
DETERMINE HOW WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE WERE POSSIBLE THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. I THINK
I'LL BE. VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
SB NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER MORAL.
ANYTHING GENERAL THE SENATE
THIS IS GOING TO BE A LAST CALL
FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. LAST
CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR. SENATOR MITCHELL-
TURN IT OVER TO YOU FOR THE
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THAT THE PRESIDENT THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR CONVERSATIONS- LET
ME REPEAT. THIS BILL AND THE
ACTIONS TAKEN. BY BOTH HOUSES
OF THE LEGISLATURE. INCLUDES
FIVE POINT THREE BILLION IN
FUNDS ABOVE EL CFF TO HELP WITH
THE IMPACT OF COLD IT. AND
CLASSROOM BASS CHARTERS RECEIVE
THESE FUNDS JUST LIKE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ANA AND EVEN NON
CLASSROOM BASS CHARTERS RECEIVE
A SMALLER PORTION OF THAT
ALLOCATION. THAT'S NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO THERE IS NO CAP ON
GROW. FUNDING IS NOT BASED ON
GROWTH IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
THREE ANY REPORTED INCREASED
EIGHTY EIGHT AND NINETEEN
TWENTY WOULD BE FUNDED IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE STILL
DON'T KNOW WHAT GROWTH WILL BE
FOR ANYONE IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
NUMBER P. THIS DOES NOT TARGET.
THREE ANY SCHOOL DIFFERENTLY.
ND WHILE I APPRECIATE THE BIG
KNOWLEDGE MINT OF OUR
COLLECTIVE HARD WORK I HAVE TO
SAY THOSE WORDS FALL SHALLOW
WHEN THEY'RE FOLLOWED BY
ASSERTIONS OF TARGETING POOR
CHILDREN OF CHILDREN OF COLOR.
I WILL SAY AGAIN. THIS POLICY
DOES NOT TARGET OR TREAT ANY
SCHOOL DIFFERENTLY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE DEBATE AND I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE BUT IN
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA OR AYE
ATKINS AYE BELL FIVE FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD. I HAVE A YELLOW I
CHIANG. NO DALLY NO DODD. HI
TERRORISM HI GALGIANI BY GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. HI HILL I WAS SO. I
HER DAUGHTER I JACKSON. I JONES
NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ
NO MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE
LOCK. NO MORALE NO NIELSEN. NO
HAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN I
NUMBER I WAY CASKEY I WIENER HI
WILK NOW. PRICE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS TEN THE SIMLY NAME IS
HER CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING NINE TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE. FILE ITEM. THIRTY THREE.
THE THIRD CALL ON ME. SIX CAN
YOU PLEASE. SENATE BILL ONE
SIXTY BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AND
ACTUALLY INTO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER PRESIDENT
IF YOU DON'T MIND BEFORE PRISON
SAID BILL I JUST LIKE TO ON A
KNOWLEDGE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL.
ON THE PREVIOUS ACTION. YES
PLEASE WHY DON'T WE- JUMP BACK
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
PLEASE. I'M SORRY I WAS TRYING
TO GET YOUR ATTENTION AYE I
DIDN'T GET UP QUICK ENOUGH THE
WORLD UNDER MOST OF THE
RESOLUTIONS IF I MAY PLEASE
FIRST- THIS LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL CLARIFIES THE
FLEXIBILITY PROVIDED TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
DISTANT LEARNING. ARE ELLIE
EIGHTH MAY PROVIDE
INSTRUCTIONAL MODELS IN
COLLABORATION WITH STATE OR
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
AND TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND THAT WASN'T FORTIN
IT WAS RAISED BY OUR COLLEAGUE
AND SEVEN MONICA DURING THE
DISCUSSION AND SO I'LL BE
SUBMITTING THIS LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
CENTER MITCHELL IT'S GOING TO
LEADER GROVE LEADER GROW AT WE
APPROVE THAT AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT THANK YOU FOR SUBMITTING
THAT LETTER AND IT'S WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR. OCEAN CARRIES VALUE TO.
CAN TO PRE. THAT SENATOR. WE
DID THE READ IT BY THE GOOD
SECRETARY WE'RE NOT GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO SENATOR MITCHELL
UNDER FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT SB ONE SIXTEEN IS THE
HIGHER EDUCATION TRAILER BILL
AND CONTAIN STATUTORY CHANGES
TO IMPLEMENT THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET THAT. WE DID PASS A
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR THE BILL
AB NINETY FOUR LAST WEEK
HOWEVER THIS VERSION THAT WAS
SENT FROM THE ASSEMBLY IS
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT. IN THAT IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE AMENDMENTS
RELATED TO THE UC SAN FRANCISCO
HARASSING THEM OUT OF THE-
HEIGHTS PROJECT. LET ME SEE IF
I GET THIS RIGHT. PARNASSUS
THANK YOU THE PARNASSUS HEIGHTS
PROJECT ALL OTHER COMPONENTS OF
THE FIFTY ONE SIXTEEN ARE
IDENTICAL TO A. B. NINETY FOUR
TO REMIND YOU THEY INCLUDED THE
FIRST ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
PROP NINETY GENERAL FUND FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FROM THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR
TO THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR COMMITTEE COLLEGES
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR A
HARDSHIP WAIVER OF THIRTY
MILLION TOTAL FOR EACH DEFERRAL
MONTH. THEY CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SIXTY SIX POINT THREE MILLION
PROP NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CALL BUT NINETEEN
RESPONSIBLE I GRANT WHICH WOULD
FUN ACTIVITIES THAT SUPPORT
STUDENT LEARNING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. IT
MAINTAINS THE CAL GRANT AWARD
TO STUDENTS ATTENDING PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COLLEGES AT NINE
THOUSAND EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS IT
PROVIDES EMERGENCY FINANCIAL
AID FOR A. B. FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS THAT YOU SEE SEE IF
AND THE COMMUNITY THIS AND
FINANCE AID FOR STUDENTS TO SO
SESSION AT NEW SEE SEE IF YOU.
I ASKED FOR AND I
MUCH. CHAIRMAN GOING TO LOOK
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE FOR.
THEY'RE JUST ON THE BAY. OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. HEARINGS
NINE. BETTER SECTOR YOU PLEASE
GO THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I FELL I GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW I
CHIANG. I DOLLY. DODD. FIVE
ZERO ZERO I AYE GLAZER AYE. I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HILL AYE
HUESO. I HER TADO I JACKSON AYE
JONES. LEYVA I WIRE I MELENDEZ
NO MITCHELL HI MONNING I MORE
LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN. NO
HAN AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN I
NUMBER HI MY COUNTY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK. NOW MEN OF SIX YOU
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR JUST. NO DALLY. NO
GROWTH NO JONES NOW. BODIES
THIRTY KNOWS NINE HE SIMPLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
RIGHT NOWGONNA BE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR CENTER
I'M BURKE BE PREPARED TO
PRESENT. HE IS BETTER SECTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE HUNDRED BY SENATOR
UMBERG AN ACTUAL LIVING TO
ELECTIONS AND CALLING AN
ELECTION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY NUMBER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS TO SB THREE HUNDRED
DELETED THE BILL'S PREVIOUS
LANGUAGE SPENCER LANGUAGE THAT
WAVES THE STATUTORY DEADLINE
FOR SPECIFIED ASSEMBLY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS. LAST
THURSDAY THE STATUTORY DEADLINE
FOR THOSE MEASURES TO MAKE THE-
WHAT THE STATUTORY DEADLINE FOR
THOSE MEASURES TO MAKE THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT THE SENATE IS
BUT THESE DID NOT NO SO WE KNEW
THEIR PART. THIS IS NOT ON
PRESS AS A LEGISLATOR WAVES
DEADLINE NUMEROUS TO IN THE
PAST AND THEIR RESPECT URGE
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER OF
BURKE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS
WERE LOOK FOR DISCUSS OR DEBATE
SAID PART. I HAVE A QUESTION OF
THE- CENTER NUMBER WOULD YOU
ACCEPT THE CALL FROM CENTER
PART DO OF A TWO. ALL RIGHT AT
ALL EXCEPT DOLLARS IT I RISE
SUPPORT S. THREE HUNDRED I ALSO
WOULD THE CENTER TO GO ON. TO
SAY FOR THE RECORD WHO HIS.
FORMER WAS IF YOU COULD ANSWER
THAT ALL YEAH. WHEN ABRAHAM
LINCOLN WAS PRESENT. YES YOU
PUT IN A BIND BUT HOW CAN I SAY
YOU BY SO HERTZBERG ARE. SO
IT'S NOT OBVIOUS NOT ACCEPTABLE
TO THAT ARE BUT- THANK YOU SO
SENATOR I'M FOR RELOOK FOR DISH
TO OR TO BE ON THE- THIS IS
GOING TO BE A LAST CALL FOR THE
OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR I WAS
THE FRONT TO. THE NON. MEN OF
SEX CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I TELL. BOARD NO
BRADFORD. ON I HAVE A I CHIANG.
SALLY. NO DODD. THERE ARE OTHER
I GALGIANI I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. I HILL
HI HUESO. I TADO I JACK'S. I
JONES. NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I MONEY
I MORE LOCK NO MORE I. NO
NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE PORTS AND-
I ROTH. I GREW. I SKINNER I
STERN I I'M BURKE HI I LIKE HOW
ON AYE WE. HI WILK. MINISTER
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL ABSENT.
WELL I. CHIANG. DODD I WELL. I
IS TWENTY NINE KNOWS A THE
SIMPLY ARE CAN IN. LAYS IN
GERMAN THE SEA WE'RE NOW COULD
WE WILL ON TO I THIRTY FIVE
UNDER SOME. THIS WILL BE THE
LAST ITEM I SO FOR THE DAY.
CENTER HILLS PREPARED FOR.
MADAM SECRETARY YOU PLEASE.
SENATE THREE FIFTY BY SENATOR
AND INTO ENERGY GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR HILL THE FLOORS OR SIR
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER BRIT
THANK YOU FOR THE ARE. 2% SB
THREE FIFTY ON CONCUR. IN THAT
WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT
THE GENEROSITY OF THE MAJORITY
LEADER FOR DONATING THIS
VEHICLE- THE IMAGE TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSFORM THIS BILL TO
THE GOLDEN STATE ENERGY AT.
LAST YEAR YOU RECALL THE
LEGISLATURE IMPOSED STRICT
CONDITIONS ON P. JEANNIE TO
EXIT BANKRUPTCY IS A TRANSFORM
UTILITY. THIS BILL SB THREE
FIFTY HOLD TO BE P. JEANNIE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR MEETING THOSE
REQUIREMENTS AND PROVIDES OUR
STATE WITH A FAIL SAFE IN CASE.
THE NEW P. JEANNIE FALL SHORT
OF EXPECTATIONS. SB THREE FIFTY
AUTHORIZES THE CREATION OF A
NEW ENTITY. GOLDEN STATE ENERGY
A NON PROFIT PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION WHICH REACHED IN
AND TAKE OVER PGA FAILS EMERGE
FROM BANKRUPTCY. THE GENIE
FAILED TO TRANSFER FROM AS
RECALL BY AB TEN FOR FOUR. THIS
IS NOT THE CREW. OF A STATE RUN
UTILITY. GSE WOULD BE IN THE-
OPERATING AS A- VERGE GSC IS A
FOR SAFE ENSURE IN IT IS THERE
TO PROVIDE POWER SHOULD P.
JEANNIE FAIL US AGAIN. I WANT
TO THANK MY CO AUTHORS ON THIS
MEASURE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
AND SENATORS DODD AND MCGUIRE
WHO HAVE CARRIED THE VISION
WITH ME ON TRANSFORMING P.
JEANNIE. COLLEGE SB THREE FIFTY
IS IN A BILL WE WANT. WHAT WE
WANT IS FOR P. JEANNIE TO BE A
REFORM UTILITY. IT IS A BILL WE
NEED TO PROTECT P. GENIES RATE
PAYERS. AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL CALLING. THANK YOU CENTER
HELD DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR. CENTER BOARD IT'S
GOOD AFTERNOON FOR SURE SIR
THANK YOU. I WANT TO MAKE
CERTAIN IN MAYBE IF THE AUTHOR
CAN- CLOSE. WITH SOME
INFORMATION. THIS GS SEEING IS
ONE OF ONLY ON THE CONDITION
THAT P. JEANNIE DOES NOT
SUCCESSFULLY REORGANIZE EMERGE
OUT OF BANKRUPTCY NUMBER TWO
THAT THIS DOES NOT INHIBIT
ANOTHER CORPORATE ENTITY FOR
COMPETING IN A REORGANIZE WERE
LIQUIDATED FORM OF P. JEANNIE-
IN THREE IS IT LEGALLY REQUIRED.
AT THE WE HAVE A DEFAULT ENTITY
TO ASSUME THE RESPONSIBILITIES
OF PROVIDING ENERGY SO IS THIS
A LEGAL NECESSITY IN OTHER
WORDS FOR US TO HAVE SOME SORT
OF CORPORATE- ON DEFAULT-
ENTITY MADE AVAILABLE IF YOU
COULD ANSWER THOSE NEAR CLOSING
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER HELLO ANSWER
CENTER BOARD IS IN HIS CLOSING
APPRECIATE THAT CENTER BRIDGES
FOR GOING TO GO TO CENTER
WIENER AND THEN TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER CENTER WIENER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT ON.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY AND I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FROM- SAN MATTEO FROM
OUR SISTER DISTRICT- WHO- WHO
HAS SHOWN EXTRAORDINARY
LEADERSHIP- AROUND- THE FAILED
COMPANY NOTICE PIGEON THE- AND
OTHER RELATED ISSUES FOR A VERY
LONG TIME AND I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE. OF HIS
LEADERSHIP. EARLIER THIS YEAR I
DID INTRODUCED LEGISLATION. TO
MAKE PEACE IN A- A PUBLICLY
OWNS- UTILITY AS PART OF A
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATION- AND
IN MY VIEW- WE DON'T NEED TO
GIVE P. GINNY ANOTHER CHANCE.
PLEASE AS A FALCON. THAT HAS
BECAUSE PROBLEMS SUCH
COLLEAGUES YOUR ALL AWARE. MASS
MASS FROM. COMPANIES TO GIVE IT
EVERY OP. TO SUCCEED AND IT HAS
IT HAS ALLOWED ITS EFFORTS TO
TEAR. ON UP. CAUSING THESE FIRE
AND I THINK IT'S TO MAKE
TEACHING OF CALL ON YOUTH. ARE
WE HAVING GREAT EXAM IN THIS OF
PUBLIC HONORS TO YOU. TO
PREVENT RATIO ALL OVER IN. OUR
I UNDERSTAND THAT MY VIEW IS
NOT THE PROGRAM. VIEW OF THE
LAW. AND I HONOR RESPECT. AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS. BILL
THANK YOU. THANK BUT CENTER.
RELATED BEFORE HOURS. THANK YOU
MISTER THANK MISTER BRIEFLY I
TWO ONE TO MEANT AUTHOR AND
ALSO SENATOR AYE. THINK THAT
IMPORTANT SHE IS THAT THE IS A
NET COMPONENT OF A LAW
STRUCTURE DEALING WITH ARE MADE
LAST YEAR FOR DI. TOGETHER WITH
BANK OF IN THE CAN OF THE BANK.
TOGETHER WITH P. IS AND PROVIDE
WITH THE BACKS IN THE THAT HAVE
THE EIGHT P. JEANNIE BANKER. TO
BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT IN A
THOUGHT WAY MAKE THAT FOR THE
PAYERS AND CAL SO I STAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
APPLAUD THE A THE OFFICE FOR
THE SUFFERED A OUR PRO CAN
OFFICE IN PUTTING THIS TO. AND
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISS MAJORITY LEE GOOD
AFTERNOON SAN MORE LOCKED
FLOORS ARE. THANK RISK
PRESIDENTE WANT TO THANK AUTHOR.
EXPLANATION MADE THIS MORNING A
ARE. ENERGY AND CATIONS
COMMITTEE. SO I JUST WANNA JUST
SURE A COUPLE FIVE ONE THE TERM
FEEL CALM KEEPS USE AND I'M
HERE TO MAY EXCUSE FOR PJ BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S IN THE FULL
STORY I DON'T KNOW. WHAT
IMPACTS. REGULATIONS THAT HAVE
COME OUT OF SACRAMENTO AND
RENEWABLE ENERGY MANDATES THAT
HAVE COME OUT OF SACRAMENTO.
HOW THAT IMPACTED. MANAGERIAL
DECISIONS THAT IMPACTED P.
JEANNIE. AND SO I'D LIKE TO SEE
THE BOOK SOME TIME ON HOW THIS
THING ALL. UNFOLDED BUT I AM
VERY CONCERNED MISTER PRESIDENT
AND NATIONALIZING. A PUBLICLY
TRADED COMPANY AND I'LL BE
OPPOSED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER MORLOCK
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. ANY DISCO
AND DIGITAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. CENTER
HERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MISTER PRESIDENT I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY AND- TO RESPOND
TO A COUPLE OF THE QUESTIONS IN
THE CONCERNS THIS OF THIS
LEGISLATION. IS AND IT IS
CORRECT- BY- BY THE GOOD
SENATOR THAT IT WILL ONLY. GO
INTO EFFECT IF P. JEANNIE DOES
NOT SUCCESSFULLY EXIT FROM
BANKRUPTCY AND ACQUIRE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO PAY-
FIRE VICTIMS AND TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THEIR
RESTRUCTURING PLAN- SO THAT'S
THE ONLY TO OR IF THEY FAIL
AGAIN. BY CLOSING THE
DEVASTATION OR DESTRUCTION THAT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE IN.
QUALIFY WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK
AND THE THRESHOLDS AND TRIGGER
POINTS THAT THE UP OF THE P.
SHE HAS ESTABLISHED IN P.
GENIES EXIT PLAN WITH THEM.
SECONDLY THE OF- THE PEACH THIS
PARTICULAR OR AT THAT
PARTICULAR TIME. IN PLACE
NGUYEN P. JEANNIE FAILS OR NOT
EXIT BANKRUPTCY THE P. YOU SEE
WILL PUT THE COMPANY INTO
RECEIVERSHIP. AND IN THAT
RECEIVERSHIP OPPORTUNITY. DAY
WILL HAVE THE- THE CHOICE OF
PROVIDE PROVIDING OR OFFERING
THE COMPANY TO NOT JUDGE GOLDEN
STATE ENERGY BUT TO ANYONE WHO
A PRIVATE COMPANY ANOTHER
CORPORATION INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY WHATEVER IT IS THAT
MAYBE INTERESTED. IN PURCHASING
OR TAKING OVER. P. JEANNIE AT
THAT TIME. OF THE OF THIS
RELIGIOUS IS AN- THAT WE ARE
THE ONLY ONE OR THAT WE ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE THIS ENTITY IN
PLACE FOR P. JEANNIE TO EXIT
BANKRUPTCY. THE BUSES YOU SURE
THAT THERE. A AN- IN PLAY. THAT
IS NOT AN INSTRUMENTALITY OF
THE STATE. THAT CAN BE IN A
POSITION AND WOULD BE IN A
POSITION TO FACILITATE AN EASY
TRANSITION. SURE THAT THE
CUSTOMERS OF P. JEANNIE WILL BE
MAINTAINED THAT THERE WILL BE
AN ORGANIZATION IN PLACE THAT
CAN CONTINUE WITH THE OFFERED
UP THE- THE OPERATION OF
PROVIDING A GOOD SOLID UTILITY
OR GOOD UTILITY FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE OTHER ASPECT OF THAT WAS
REFERENCED BY OUR GOOD SENATOR
FROM FROM RIVERSIDE. IF WE WANT
TO. SPEND A FEW MORE MONTHS
DISCUSSING THE CHALLENGES THAT
P. JEANNIE FACED OVER THE LAST
TWENTY OR THIRTY YEARS IN THE
REASONS THAT THEY ARE IN THE
POSITION THAT THEY'RE IN I
THINK ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS LOOK
AT THE FEDERAL CRIMINAL COURT
THAT HAS THEM NOW UNDER SHOOT
FOUND THEM GUILTY OF SIX
FELONIES A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO
AND THEY'RE STILL ON PROBATION
TODAY OR THE WONDERFUL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. FOR THE COUNTY OF
BUTTE WHO FOUND THEM GUILTY OF
EIGHTY FIVE FELONIES. A YOU
LOOK AT THE CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR
OF THIS COMPANY HISTORICALLY-
OVER THAT TIME PERIOD. YOU LOOK
AT THE FACT THAT THE DIVERTED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. THAT WERE ATTRIBUTED
SET ASIDE FOR SAFETY FOR
MAINTENANCE. FOR OPERATIONS
THAT MONEY WAS SET ASIDE BY THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
THEY DIVERTED THAT THOSE FUNDS.
TO BONUSES TO INCENTIVES. AND
FOR PROFITS. BECAUSE THE ONLY
WAY AN INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY
CAN INCREASE THEIR PROFITS
ABOVE THE RATE OF RETURN. IS TO
CUT EXPENSES. AND THAT'S WITH
THIS COMPANY DID. THAT'S WHY
THEY WERE FOUND GUILTY THAT'S
WHY WE NEED A BACKUP PLAN TO GO
FORWARD I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR- WOULD CALL IT. CAN WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OUR I ARE
TO I AT AYE BELL HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I CAN I ADAM.
CHIANG NO DALLY NO DODD. HI
THERE ARE. I GALGIANI. HI
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG I HILL HI HI WITH ON
I HER TIME. HI JACKSON HI JOAN
NO LEYVA. I REQUIRE I WILL IN
THIS NO MITCHELL. I MONNING I
MORE LAW NO MORE. NO NIELSEN.
NO HAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN HI
NUMBER I LIKE CAST. I WIENER HI
WELL. HI SIX CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL ABSENT IN ONCE. FOR CUT BY
AT ALL HI. HIGH IS THE THIRD
KNOWS EIGHT THESE THEM IT'S
KERN IN THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
MEMBERS ARE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
NINE IN GOING TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WE'RE GOING BACK TO ON
BUT- LOOKING AT FILE ITEM NINE.
FIVE ITEM NO. UNDER UNFINISHED.
CENTER PER PREPARED PRESENT AN
INSPECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTEEN BY
SOME PORTS AND ACTUALLY THE CAL
VICTIM COME. BOARD MAKING
APPROPRIATE THEIR AND TAKE. AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY OF TO
TAKE EFFECT MEET. PORTANTINO
FLOORS YOU GOOD AT SIR THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND ARE
FOUR SEVENTY ITS INNER MAY. TO
APPROACH APPROX FIVE POINT ONE
MILLION TO. VICTIMS BOARD FOR
THE OF SO OR S. CONVICTION CLAY.
THE BILL IS BACK IN SENATE
CONCUR WITH AFTER WAS A MAN IN
THE S. TO. A PAYMENT FOR TO DO
CLAIMS. BY THE ARTIST JANUARY
ONE OF THE LAST OF BY THIS BY.
ALL OF THE NEW ARE PAYING. TO
PUT IS FOUND TO BE FACT IN. OF
THE CRIME FOR BRING CARCERI AND
IN CONVICTIONS VAGUE BY THE
COURT. AS BEFORE SEVEN. ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAD HERE
ON VOTES IN THE S. ACTUALLY
ASKED. FOR YOUR- ON THIS CLAIMS.
SENATORS IS DISCUSSION OR TO ON
THE- LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION
OR TO ON THE FLOOR. HEARING BUT
OF SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ACTIONS BY DEL FIVE FORGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T I
CHIANG HI DOLLY. GOD HI THERE I
WASN'T I GOT CHEN. AYE GLAZER
AIKENS. HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL HI HI HUESO I HEARD.
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE HI MULLIN. MITCHELL I
MONNING I MORE LAW. HI PEARL.
NO NIELSEN. PAN FIVE PORTANTINO
I RALPH HI RUBIO. I SKINNER HI
STERN HI I'M. EIGHTY FIVE MY
CASTING I WIENER. HURTADO
MELENDEZ. NIELSEN WELL. SIZE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS TO THE SIM
LIMITS ARE CONCURRED IN THANK
YOU FOR THE HARD WORK TODAY
SENATORS IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS MADAM
PRO TEN THE DESK IS GOING.
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION
WILL BE THIS THURSDAY JULY
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY AT NINE AM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THINKING
THAT A PROTEIN THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL FIVE PM TO
WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE PLACED. WE'RE GONNA
RECONVENE ON THURSDAY AT NINE
AM THANK YOU CENTERS.